what's the biggest lie you ever told
another celebrity
uh
love the movie ever sat through an
entire performance of cats
no
no
well triple
really for what god this is so scary
when are you gonna hit me with the stuff
i love andrew lloyd webber do you
al
i pull it off
why lie okay there we go
oh yes i inhaled
i inhaled and i liked it it's not
admissible so who gives a damn would you
tell somebody their toupee was wrong
yes you would have you ever done it
yes it's not a good thing to do really
no it goes to the core of humanity
marianne or ginger
both boat with a little mrs howell
thrown in
you know what i'm saying stop winking at
me yeah okay we have a probability of
deception at 99
99
whoa
wow
that that means only one thing
i'm deceiving myself everybody's been
real nice well that's because you have
big jugs
i mean your boobs are huge i mean i want
to squeeze them that's the the fun part
about this movie is it's got everything
we didn't want to lose the frenetic
craziness the the
the energy the most fun of this
character is that it's not really about
you know
lying as much as it is
if you had to tell the truth what it
would be like simmons is
he old have been out of the game years
ago but he can't stay home because he
hates his wife
he gave me a close to an aneurysm what
the hell are you doing
i'm kicking my ass divine
i get bruises you know i i'm pretty good
at
gauging whether or not i'm going to get
hurt
really seriously hurt sometimes i go
anyway because it's
you know it's on screen i want to be run
over by a chariot basically
[Music]
my father actually passed that down he
created the claw you just never knew
when his arm was going to animate itself
and come to life and chase you around
the house and tickle you until you pee
so
that's what he works the whole pattern
everything is his really on that yeah
that's great he lives on in a lot of my
work though he's you know i'm always
stealing from my dad what's wrong with
me
i'm getting what i deserve i'm reaping
what i sew
good thing you didn't ask me about the
movie
[Laughter]
did you like the movie jim keep that
[Music]